le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
respectez le bien-être animal tout en
produisant un produit de qualité
c'est la mission quotidienne de la
famille vitry agriculteurs à la plaine
des cafres depuis plusieurs générations
père et fils perpétue la tradition
familiale à l'occasion de la 41e édition
de la foire agricole de bras-panon
ils vont aller récupérer le prix de la
meilleure qualité de lait pour la
troisième année consécutive
[Musique]
allez allez 5h30
comme tous les jours à l'aube
henri-claude commence la traite de ses
vaches commence à laver la bonne qualité
[Musique]
le lait et le bétail n'ont aucun secret
pour ce fils d'agriculteur mes parents
des victimes depuis plus de 25 ans quand
même il aime à travailler dedans avec
goût métier comment commencer à au moins
70 ça là commence avec les bouts de chou
on m'a tendu deux ans et demi avant
produisent une production pour laquelle
henri claude s'impliquer s'applique
jusqu'à la dernière goutte
on contrôle bien on bave dans l'appareil
copé l'a directement son lait servira à
la fabrication de produits laitiers
distribués dans les grandes surfaces de
l'île
mais ce qui différencie le tamponnais
c'est la qualité de sa production
pour la troisième année consécutive le
département lui décerne le prix de la
meilleure qualité du lait une récompense
qui résultent de quelques principes
essentiels pour l'agriculteur le
bien-être de l'animal en première chose
si c'est l'alimentation et l'hygiène de
traite cette heure alors que pour
beaucoup la journée commence à peine
henri claude et son fils entament la
deuxième grande étape de la matinée
l'alimentation des vaches
voilà je prépare les gonades 10 de leurs
données de l'allemand et après bons
niveaux de ratios d'aliments même on est
à 12 kg après benjamin a décidé de
suivre les traces de son père et son
grand père dans la famille vitry
l'histoire se répète le plus petit fuite
d'envoi par rapport aux grands parents
j'adapte et arrco telle exploitation des
bobards en vain de ce que j'étais tout
le temps avec les grands-parents des
vacances lesquels et voilà match comme
un c je suis tombé dedans comme ça de
ses aînés il a hérité de la même rigueur
et des mêmes principes
owen animaux stressés fait un imac rap
pas vraiment bien produire et kibaki a
développé des problèmes n'ayant fait
c'est pas c'est pas un autre avantage
avant à l'image presser au pacte voilà
cette année c'est lui qui ira récupérer
le prix de son père à la foire de bras
panon
c'est un rendez vous incontournable pour
l'ensemble des agriculteurs mais aussi
pour les réunionnaises et les
réunionnais puisque la foire agricole de
bras-panon fait partie maintenant et
bien des événements majeurs dans l'île
chaque année eh bien nous mettons en
avant quelques personnes qui ont fait
des efforts particuliers et qui ont
réussi à travers le travail a montré
donc la qualité de leur savoir-faire
agricole et donc c'est pour cela qu'il y
en a qui sont primés mais encore une
fois s'il fallait donner un prix
beaucoup des centaines de personnes
mériterait d'être soutenus et d'être
récompensés une belle reconnaissance
pour un métier qui tient plus de la
vocation sa métier dur mais c'est quand
c'est une passion bien un métier
vraiment bien parce que c'est un métier
qu'il ya de l'avenir dans le lait un
avenir assuré chez les vitry pour le
benjamin de la famille pas de doute ce
monde c'est le sien moi j'aime le métier
à fringe coup c'est pas cessé à mon
avantage dès que j'ai une bonne
expérience quand même depuis je vois
comment il faut après voilà ils m'ont
toujours aussi bien choisi ce que je
vais faire comme métier peu importe le
métier
salut salut agira c'est pas
mon pas poussée via ce métier là je suis
tombé dedans henri-claude et benjamin
prévoit d'agrandir l'exploitation
prochainement l'avenir il le contemple à
deux les yeux rivés vers le même horizon
[Musique]
pour la troisième année consécutive
l'exploitation agricole d'henri claude
vitry a reçu le prix de la meilleure
qualité du lait un prix décerné par le
département à l'occasion de la foire
agricole de bras-panon se déroulant du 4
au 13 mai la foire agricole de bras
panon et la plus grande manifestation du
monde agricole réunionnais pour
l'occasion près de 200 exposants et 1500
animaux seront présents mais aussi
divers animations comme des ateliers
concerts ou conférences pour plus
d'informations rendez vous sur le site
du département au www.dna.fr
[Musique]